So for programmers the most natural
type of consistency is called sequential
consistency, and it says that
the result of any execution should be
as if accesses executed by each
processor were executed in order and
accesses among different processors
were arbitrarily interleaved.
So we are allowed to let processors
take turns in terms of accessing,
or let one access several times
before another one does, and so on.
So we can do anything we want to
interleave the accesses from different
processors.
But what comes from each of
the processors needs to be exactly
In program order.
So, the simplest implementation
of sequential consistency
is one where we remove
the should be as if.
So, pretty much,
any execution proceeds by executing
accesses from each processor in order.
So, a core performs the next
memory access only when all
previous accesses are complete.
So in the code it waits for a flag
to be set and then prints the data.
We cannot read the data until
the read of the flag has completed.
Remember that the problem in previous
examples was that we branch predict this
and leave and read the data then read
the flag and confirm our prediction.
Now, we can still predict, but when we
get to reading the data we have to delay
that until the flag has been read.
At which point, if we read 1 here,
by that time the writes to the flag and
data complete and
we will read the correct data here.
Or if we read 0 here then we would
correct the miss prediction and
go back to waiting here.
So either way,
you cannot print wrong data anymore
under sequential consistency here.
So this works pretty well except that
it's really, really bad for performance.